[Musique]
oui
on
[Musique]
je suis fanja rakotomamonjy cofondatrice
de city d1 foutraque spécialisé dans la
cuisine du monde que j'ai créé avec ma
soeur lalatiana rakotomamonjy je suis là
la tiendra quand on a mangé j'ai cofondé
le sou trucks avec ma soeur et je suis
responsable de la communication du
marketing et aussi une partie
commerciale
[Musique]
oui
et principalement proposé aux villageois
aux fêtes de voyager à travers travers
notre cuisine du monde
mon activité a consisté d'abord au début
au montage du projet donc tout ce qui
est prévisionnel est aussi tout ce qui
est plein d'action communication
[Musique]
comme là on peut trouver aussi bien la
rue des saucisses et crevettes que le
poulet m'a fait que tilikum carnet et
puis au niveau des desserts pareil nous
restons sur des mois le présent de la
moelleux
chocolat passion un moelleux patates
douces banni c'est surtout son des
masseurs sur ce qu'elle voulait faire
son besoin son rêve
on va avoir quelque chose de concret et
voilà que cette chose concrète c'est se
up et ça ça rassemble un peu ce
que je fais de la cuisine et si on est
un peu allez voir à aller à la rencontre
des gens
[Musique]
on a recherché les conseils localement
au début par le ski tube puis par le par
le biais jeu nous avons pour l'étude de
marché au niveau consommateurs et fait
réaliser un questionnaire à son âge en
ligne ça nous a permis de cadrer l'offre
d'une part et puis pour la partie titre
concurrence on l'a fait par nous mêmes
par des recherches sur internet
[Musique]